no rules this time just a little history
Alexander Hamilton was many things aide
to General George Washington Secretary
of the Treasury Major General of the US
Army lover cheater duelist musical
phenomenon but few knew his immensely
influential role in American Free Press
law just months before his fatal duel
today we think of libel as defamatory
falsehood false written statements
especially lies but sometimes honest
mistakes that injure a person's
reputation and we also think of libel as
a civil claim criminal libel
prosecutions are very rare in 1700s
England though Oh criminal libel cases
were common and they covered many
written statements that harmed a
person's reputation even if they were
true such statements were outlawed in
part because they were seen as likely to
produce duels Hamilton died because of
his harsh statements albeit oral
statements about Aaron Burr and when
said about government officials such
defamatory statements again even if true
were seen as undermining the
government's authority the greater the
truth the greater the libel some said
American law was based on English law so
many Americans assumed American law
would take the same view in the famous
colonial era 1735 John Peter Zenger
trial the defense had argued that truth
must be a defense in libel cases but
though the jury acquitted Sanger such
jury decisions set no legally binding
precedent enter Alexander Hamilton in
1803 Thomas Jefferson was president
Hamilton was a prominent New York lawyer
when Harry Croswell an anti Jefferson
newspaper editor was prosecuted in New
York state court for labelling Jefferson
Hamilton came to kras Welles defense
cause Welles publication had alleged
that Thomas Jefferson had paid another
editor James Callender
to make scurrilous accusations against
Washington and Adams this allegation of
cause Welles injured Jefferson's
reputation the prosecution charged thus
making it libel without regard to
whether it was true and it also injured
the nation making it so-called seditious
libel cross well was convicted after the
trial judge instructed the jury that
truth was not the defense in libel cases
Krauss well appealed and Hamilton
representing Krauss well argued that
truth should have been a defense the
liberty of the press consists in my idea
in publishing the truth from good
motives and for justifiable ends
we reflect on government on magistrates
or individuals it is essential to say
not only that the measure is bad and
deleterious but to hold up to the people
who is the author that in this our free
and elective government he may be
removed from the seat of power today
that standard actually would diminish
First Amendment protection at least as
to matters of public concern the court
held in 1964 prosecutors must always
prove an alleged libel was false
regardless of whether it was said from
good motives and for justifiable ends
but in 1803 Hamilton's position was a
great step towards broader legal
protection for criticism of government
and Hamilton's positions swept the
nation not at first
the New York Court split two to two
that's leaving cause Welles conviction
standing but justice James Kent who had
become one of the most influential
judges and legal writers of the early
1800s endorsed Hamilton's view in his
opinion in 1805 the New York legislature
enacted a statute implementing
Hamilton's view that truth was always a
defense when published with good motives
and for justifiable ends phrasing that
Hamilton pioneered in the decades after
that many state constitutions were
framed precisely this way to this day
tony state constitutions contain
Hamilton's formula Hamilton and justice
Kent had become close friends in the
years before the cross web case when
they were in Albany for the court
sitting that included the Croswell
argument Hamilton Kent and a few others
had dinner together over dinner Hamilton
remarked that he thought Aaron Burr was
dangerous and untrustworthy burr was at
the time planning to run for governor of
New York that we ended up being beaten
by Morgan Lewis the trial judge in Cross
Wells case another man at the dinner
reported on these remarks which were
then referred to in an Albany newspaper
burr demanded that they be retracted
Hamilton refused burr challenged
Hamilton to a duel and Hamilton didn't
live to see his view of the freedom of
the press become part of American law
this is not legal advice if this were
legal advice it would be followed by a
bill please use responsibly written by
Eugene Bullock who is an actual
real-life First Amendment law professor
at UCLA I'm Eugene Baalak and I approved
you